شرائط من المخمل والخرز البراق هي من ابرز
اللمسات التي تظهر على فساتين الاميره
البريطانيه الراحله ديانا بالاضافه الى
بعض مقتنياتها التي تعرض ضمن مزاد خيري في
العاصمه البريطانيه لندن وهذا الفستان
الحالك السواد ارتدته ديانا خلال رقصتها
الشهيره مع جون ترافولتا كانت رائعه وهي
ترتدي هذا الفستان ونذكر جيدا نظرتها
الرائعه في تلك الليله وهي تحني براسها
للاسفل وترفع عيناها للاعلى ومنثم رقصه
الشهيره لاكثر من نصف ساعه على وقع اغاني
جون ترافولتا وهذا الفستان الذي بهر
الحضور خلال حفل عشاء اقيم في البيت
الابيض عام
1985 والذي يفوق ثمنه 300000 دولار كيف
تقدرون قيمه الفساتين انها عمليه صعبه
بالفعل فنحن نقدر قيمه وثمن الفستان في
التسعينيات وكيفيه تصميمه والمناسبه التي
ارتدي فيها سواء ا كانت مناسبه عامه ام
حفل عشاء خاص وهل التقطت الصور للاميره او
مقاطع فيديو للاميره وهي ترتديه وفيما لو
ارتبط الزي بقصه ما وهذه الفساتين تروي
ذكريات مضت ويلاحظ هنا بعض الطبع الناجمه
عن عدم تنظيف الفستان مثل يد طفل هنا
واصابع
وغيرهما كيري تيلر مشهوره بتنظيمها
المزادات الملكيه فقد عرضت رداء السباحه
الخاص بدوقه كامبريج كيت ميدلتون الذي
يروي قصه حبها بالامير ويليام والتي بدات
بارتدائها له عندما كان في جاعه وبيع هذا
الزي باكثر من 124 الف
دولار تعتبر كاثرين من الشخصيات التي تعرف
ما تريده ولديها ذوقها الخاص ولا تخاف من
ارتداء ما يحلو لها وتعتقد بانه يناسبها
وانا متاكده من ان الناس يتطلعون اليها
خلال السنوات المقبله
ويقتدى مع ديانا لا شك ان ديانا كانت
مختلفه وتمثل اميره للشعب اذ تابع الناس
قصص حبها وافراحها واحزانها وستبقى
مكانتها مميزه في قلوب
الناس مكانه مميزه للاميره الراحله ديانا
في قلوبهم وجيوبهم اذ يعتقد بان المجموعه
المكونه من عشره فساتين سوف تحصد اكثر من
مليون دولار عند بيعها في المزاد